[Musique]
une seconde
il m'a fallu une seconde je suis entré
dans son appartement il était en train
de cuisiner
debout dans sa cuisine le long du mur un
livre de recettes
il était en train de peser des pommes de
terre déjà épluchés pour faire un gratin
dauphinois pesée des pommes de terre
déjà épluché une seconde en une seconde
j'ai vu son essence la beauté de son
être j'étais amoureuse c'était 10 à 20
ans moi je passais chez lui à
l'improviste il pleuvait dehors j'avais
des cheveux trempés et j'ai commencé par
joyeusement étaler le contenu de mon sac
à main sur son canapé pour le faire
sécher
vous auriez vu le contenu de mon sac une
seconde en une seconde
lui aussi devenu raide dingue de moi je
n'ai vu dans sa merveille et je les ai
vus comme une merveille jusqu'au jour où
son appartement bien j'ai sa tendance à
tout organiser les semaines bien
planifié commencé à vraiment de taper
sur les nerfs
moi je viens d'une enfance très libre et
joyeusement bordélique chez moi par
exemple au moment de manger on ouvrait
le frigidaire en prenait ce qu'il y
avait dedans
au four et sa régaler tous ceux qui
étaient là
alors vous m'imaginez pesée des pommes
de terre déjà épluchés et il a tellement
aimé cet homme là il a tellement aimé ya
vingt ans mon côté last minute
ma tendance à l'improvisation mais à
faire partout dans l'appartement la vie
il m'a vu comme une merveille et il m'a
vu dans ma merveille jusqu'au jour où il
a commencé à sentir que c'était vraiment
n'importe quoi de vivre comme ça
et progressivement comme tous les
couples du monde nous sommes passés de
l'amour fou à un quotidien plus
difficile ça vous parle
dix ans plus tard trois enfants une
maison au boulot et beaucoup de douleur
ensemble des moments désespérant où
chaque den part en vrille quand on
n'était pas ensemble je sentais vraiment
mon amour pour lui je tenais à lui mais
si tout con aborder un sujet un moyen de
s'entendre
je me sentais désespéré j'étais
terrifiée je commençais à penser
séparation un cauchemar ça vous parle
ils se marièrent des furent heureux et
eurent beaucoup d'enfants
intox tous ces trucs de prince charmant
intox sont juste des mythes pour nous
empêcher de nous mettre au boulot parce
que l'amour c'est du travail
pour nous ça a commencé sous la forme
d'un stage un stage de couple imago
trois journées qui ont tout changé
ils nous ont fait faire des trucs
incroyables nous poser ralentir respirer
dialoguer comprendre
ces trois jours ont tout changé nous
avons là compris que nous avions fait le
recrutement parfait pour redevenir
vivant thé romantics de parler de
recrutement en amour et pourtant un
recrutement fondamental parce que nous
sommes nés des merveilles nous sommes
nés des merveilles riche de plein de
potentiel et puis nous avons fait un
voyage mais regardez les bébés capacité
à se mettre en lien ou à être dans notre
bulle de la cité tendresse sensualité
curiosité créativité joie et j'en passe
nous sommes nés de véritables merveilles
et puis nous avons fait un voyage nous
avons fait un voyage dans une famille
nous avons fait un voyage dans une
communauté nous avons fait un voyage
dans un monde qui nous à passer des
messages et qui nous a fait des
psychiatres hills alors ma langue n'a
pas fourché la cicatrice de points bleus
à l'âme cicatrices psychique alors au
cours de ce voyage nous avons placé les
parties de nous des parties de notre
vitalité des parties de notre liberté
d'être des parties de notre joie dans un
congélateur et c'est comme ça que nous
arrivons dans la vie des merveilles en
partie congelés théorie du congélateur
de points bon vous voyez un congélateur
pas celui-là il existe une autre sorte
congélateur beaucoup plus important
celui dans lequel nous avons mis des
parties de nos ya pu y avoir des deuils
de l'abus de la maltraitance mais
simplement grandir au contact des miens
va me faire décidé de conjuguer des
parties de moi exemple exemple j'ai
quatre ans j'ai 4 ans et je suis dans la
boîte à couture de mamie et j'explore
j'explore
des bobines les ciseaux j'ai quatre ans
c'est magique quand mamie reviens je
comprend immédiatement sa mine le ton de
sa voix
quelque chose va pas avec moi et j'ai
quatre ans alors je décide que ma
curiosité que ma curiosité je vais la
mettre dans mon petit congélateur
parce qu'enfant je vais toujours décidé
de mettre des parties de moi de me
séparer de partie de moi plutôt que de
risquer de perdre le lien avec l'autre
et puis en tant qu'enfant aussi je vais
faire des photos je vais faire comme des
photos du dedans de mon petit monde
j'ai mon petit album photos perso des
traits de caractère positif et négatif
des gens qui se sont occupés de moi et
vous savez ce que je vais faire arriver
dans la vie adulte
eh ben je vais tomber amoureuse de
quelqu'un qui ressemble aux photos de
mon album c'est comme ça qu'en couple on
est câblé pour se mettre dans tous nos
états pour le meilleur et pour le pire
alors je récapitule quand je tombe
amoureuse quand je tombe amoureux 1
j'ai vu la merveille je sais la
merveille que tu es 2 je suis très
vivante moi je suis resté vraiment
vivante
là où toi tu t'es beaucoup congelés
c'est là qu'on dit que les opposés
s'attirent 3g le superpouvoir d'autres
maîtres dans tous ses états et ouais je
suis dans ton album photo alors alors
sans relâche comme j'ai vu la merveille
je sais la merveille je vais aller
toucher le nerf de mettre en
métamorphose parce que je veux le grand
toi je te veux entier et sa crise
l'intelligence amoureuse s'est passé de
haye
tu me fais mal et alors je vais me
défendre dans le lien 1 tu t'es mis
tellement près de mon coeur quand tu
bouges tu passes ta main sur mes bleus
c'est douloureux
j'ai besoin de ton aide parce qu'en
couple il faut pas se tromper d'ennemi
c'est pas l'eau de mon ennemi l'ennemi
c'est les bleus de mon enfance c'est les
bleus de nos enfants ce qu'ils nous
prennent en otage dans la relation et
tout ce qui est de l'ordre de la
critique du blâme des mouvements
d'humeur de la colère tout ça c'est
juste les détours de notre coeur pour
parler de besoin profond et on doit
apprendre à les dire autrement parce
qu'en coupe nous avons une mission est
la mission du couple c'est nous rendre à
notre merveille redevenir entier vivent
décongeler et ça pique
vous savez c'est picotements des mains
après la neige on a vite fait de croire
que c'est le froid qui fait mal non le
froid en dehors c'est le sens qui ramène
de la vie qui nous brûle alors on a pris
rendez vous j'ai un scoop pour vous
entre amoureux même si on vit ensemble
24 heures sur 24
on doit prendre des rendez-vous dans
l'agenda avec un ordre du jour un
process comme au bureau c'est comme ça
que tous les deux dans des dialogues on
a pu faire le voyage et accueillir un
petit garçon de l'histoire de mon mari
qui avait toujours du danger pour être
aimé et qu'on a pu accueillir et donner
de l'amour ensemble à une petite fille
de mon voyage de l'enfance qui avait pas
mal manqué de repères et ses conflits
récurrents sur le thème bazar rangement
improvisation planification tous ces
moments où on s'était mis en dispute
tout ça s'est dissous
j'ai un deuxième scoop pour vous le
conflit s'est pas un problème c'est le
coeur du réacteur
c'est précisément le rendez-vous à 2
pour transformer le plomb en or et sans
outil sans conscience on transforme le
plomb en bouillie parce que nos conflits
sont des cadeaux le conflit c'est la
croissance qui toquent à la porte mais
nous emballons ces cadeaux avec un
papier tellement repoussons que personne
ne veut les ouvrir
qui veut de la colère du rejet de la
violence de la mauvaise humeur de la
critique de la victimisation personne
perd sonne alors cet homme et moi à
chaque conflit qui s'invite
nous nous asseyons nous respirons
nous nous connectons et nous faisons ce
voyage pour éclairer l'enfance dans la
sécurité dans la connexion ouvrira deux
ses congélateurs qui nous empêche de
nous aimer totalement
c'est comme c'est comme une méditation
relationnel pour libérer en douceur les
cris du dedans les maîtres à une autre
place le couple est un voyage
initiatique
mesdames messieurs attention
le couple nous met en danger de vie
alors vivons
et je résiste pas à vous présenter mon
laboratoire de vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]